- All right, band.
Let's finish out strong
with something super cool
trending on social, this
is "What I'm liking."
(rock music)
So, there's a series of videos
that have been taking TikTok by storm.
It's simply a model on
the London Underground
lip syncing and dancing
during her train ride.
It is awesome.
- Woo!
- She is known as Tube Girl.
Her videos often capture
tens of millions of views
and has led to the
copycat Tube Girl trend.
She's even had some big
names co-star in her videos,
including Ginger Spice,
Yungblud, and Troye Sivan.
We have Tube Girl, aka
Sabrina with us now.
Come on over, Sabrina.
- Hello!
- Looking beautiful, yes.
- Yeah, you too.
- Just stunning.
So how did this start?
- Oh, my God.
So I graduated university
in June and then I moved.
- Congratulations, wow.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah.
Oh.
So, I finished law school and
I was like, you know what?
I cannot.
- You finished law school?
We're just skipping over that.
You just, okay, all right.
(Tube Girl laughs)
- Yeah, it was a bit of a tough one
and I thought to myself, you know what?
I'm not gonna do this for my life.
- Okay.
- And I just was
getting into anything
that I could possibly do
that was creative.
- Yay.
- So I was alone in my
house in London in summer,
and I was thinking, okay, what can I do?
I started listening to loads of music.
I started dancing around in my house.
So, I went down to the Tube
and I was on the way to my friend's house
and I was just like, listening to my music
and I was like, bopping my head.
And then the wind like, hits me.
- Yeah.
- Like, and I had my hair
like all blown out,
and I was like, you know what
would look so good right now
if I like, recorded myself.
Yeah.
- So you do so much.
So, you get on the Tube and
you just make these videos.
What are people doing while
you're making the videos?
- London doesn't care.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- Are they literally just
like brr-brr-brr-brr?
- They look.
- Like just waiting there.
- And they're like, no, I
can't deal with this today.
And you know what?
I'm like, you know what?
I'm just gonna do my thing.
They really love, like not
caring about what's around them.
Everyone's in their own head.
- This is what I love about New York.
- Yeah.
- I moved here
and everybody is in their own world
doing their own thing.
- Oh, my God.
- It's awesome.
- I did it here!
- Yeah.
- And I brought a leaf blower
'cause you don't have wind here.
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God, girl, wait.
So, you are walking around
with somebody just like brr-brr!
- (indistinct)
- A leaf blower is a lot of wind.
- And nobody cared.
- Oh, my God.
- Literally nobody looked up.
- I love this city so much.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- So I was like, this is
my first time in New York.
My first time in America ever.
- Oh, welcome.
- Oh, thank you!
- That's awesome.
- I made it, Mom!
I made it!
- I made it, Mom.
Oh, that's awesome.
- Thanks.
- Well, thank you so much, Sabrina.
I'm liking your post
right now.
- Thank you!
- So we've hit the end of the show
and this is usually when
we give our guests $1,000,
courtesy of our season
long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show".
Did you know that?
- No.
- Well, it's true.
Since Sabrina's doing so well,
you know, since she's
doing so well for herself,
we thought we'd give it to
someone in the audience.
So, are you cool with that?
Are you cool with that?
(audience cheering)
Anybody want $1,000 here?
All right.
I want you to look at that screen
and the money's going to
whoever the camera lands on.
Let's do this!
(drum roll beats)
(audience cheering)
(energetic rock music)
See, I couldn't see.
Oh.
I was trying to find you.
- Wow.
- Hi!
First of all, I love your sweater.
- Girl.
- And wait,
what is your name?
- I'm a little shook right now.
I was not expecting.
My name is Emmy Lamansa.
- Emmy.
- Yes.
- Oh, I love that name.
- Thank you.
- What are you gonna do with $1,000?
- Girl, I'm getting married next year.
So, that's gonna go straight
to the marriage box.
- Congratulations!
- Yes, yes.
- What a beautiful way to celebrate.
- Thank you so much.
- That's amazing!
- You're amazing.
- Spend it on your dress.
That's what I say.
- Maybe I'll spend it on like --
- Yeah.
- the booze.
- You know what, that's a better pick.
- Exactly.
- Dresses come and go,
but people getting drunk
at wedding receptions
last forever.
- Timeless.
Timeless, timeless.
- Well, enjoy your wedding.
- Thank you.
- And congratulations.
That's awesome.
(audience cheers)
Thank you so much to
Sabrina for joining us.
And thank you to all our
guests, Kenan Thompson,
Sean Paul, Manuel Turizo, Karen and Rick,
and of course, (indistinct).
Have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.
(upbeat rock music)